- What's happenin' forum?
Okay, so we're gonna check
the results from the giveaway,
just so you know it's legit,
nutrition, psychic journal,
total entries, 1882,
which is awesome.
Winners.
Ready?
Go.
Winners to draw one winner
'cause we have one prize,
650 potential users that can win.
Let's draw.
Drawing.
(mellow music)
The winner is Thea Zental,
from Germany.
Well, congratulations.
You are the winner of the giveaway.
I will be contacting you via
the email that you provided,
your Gmail.
Thanks for entering the contest, everyone.
It was a lot of fun.
We'll do some more contests,
'cause I'm getting sent
products all the time.
Maybe I'll do a cash prize,
or one of these things.
You guys gave my Twitter
following a huge boost,
which was awesome.
Talk to you soon.
(popping techno music)
♪ Yes yes ♪
All right, how's it going everybody.
Welcome back to "Better Ideas."
Today we're talking about
focus, how to focus,
why you should focus, and yeah,
that's basically about it.
In a world where distraction
is becoming more and more of a problem,
where social media is
designed like slot machines,
buzzing in your pocket,
rewarding you with notifications
and the prospect of human connection.
It's really hard to just
focus on something boring
for a long period of time.
And I get more and more
questions in the comment section
being like, "How do I focus on something
I don't like focusing on?
Or something I need to focus
on, but it's just boring."
I'm here to help you with that.
And I have struggled
with this my whole life.
I thought I had ADHD for
pretty much my entire life,
and I might still have ADHD,
but I think I fixed it without drugs.
And a lot of it came
down to some simple tips
that I just had to practice
pretty religiously,
but it pretty much
solved my focus problems.
Didn't eliminate them completely.
I still get distracted by
video games and social media,
just like everyone else,
but I'm actually able to stay focused
for a really long period of time.
And it saved my life.
So I want to save your life too.
So we're gonna jump right in.
(mellow techno music)
I was editing this video and I realized,
that the audio is all messed
up for tip number one.
So that's why it looks a little different.
Anyways, tip number one is
to unstimulate your brain.
So I don't know if
you've ever noticed this,
but whenever you're
bingeing memes on Reddit
or playing Apex, your
brain is really stimulated.
And so when you try to hop into
doing something slower pace,
like reading a book or writing an essay,
it's really, really hard to do that.
And that has a lot to do with the fact
that you've conditioned your brain
to expect these feel good chemicals
like dopamine and serotonin.
So when you're not getting that
from something slower paced,
like reading a book or writing an essay,
it's really boring in comparison.
So what you should do to
fix that is take a break
from these stimulating activities
that you were just doing.
Take a walk, go to the gym,
maybe go to the library
and start reading a book.
Meditation is really good.
Maybe take a hot shower,
but you probably don't want to be in there
for like half an hour,
kind of a waste of time.
The point being, unstimulate your brain,
give yourself a reset,
stop activating it with
so much stimulation.
That way when you hop into
doing something slower pace,
it actually feels like you're
getting a natural amount
of feel-good chemicals for doing it.
This is also why I am such a huge believer
in doing your most important work
first thing in the morning.
Set a time where you can
wake up a little earlier
than you normally wake up
to tackle that beast that
you've been avoiding.
You'll find that six to eight
hours or however many sleep,
however many sleeps.
However (chuckles) much
sleep you get in a night,
when you've had six to eight
hours to reset your brain,
you'll find that boring
activities are actually,
you're actually able to
focus on them a lot easier.
This might sound like basic advice,
but one of the most powerful tools
in your entire productivity arsenal,
is to put your phone
on do not disturb mode.
That way when you enter a flow state,
which we'll talk about in the final tip,
you're not pulled out of that flow state
every two minutes, because
somebody sent you a meme,
or like, let's see, what do
I get notifications about?
Yeah, someone sent me an email,
somebody on an Instagram
group chat, I don't know,
posted something.
There's a Discord thing.
It's all meaningless stuff.
None of this is nearly as important,
as doing my most important
video editing for my clients
early in the morning.
So stop letting other people
spend your time for you.
This morning productivity time is for you
to do your most important work.
So treat it with respect.
All these other people
who want your attention
can get it later on in the day,
once you've done your duty.
(bass techno music)
Okay, tip number two, this is
one of my personal favorites,
and that is, create a sacred
productivity playlist.
So most people have a playlist
that they listen to when
they're trying to be productive
or do homework or something like that.
Usually it's sort of a minimal
electronic background noise,
or some Lofi Chillhop or
some alpha waves or whatever.
When you listen to a particular sound,
or if you get in the habit of listening
to a particular kind of music
while you're being productive,
then your brain will start
to make the association
that that music is productivity music.
And whenever you hear that music,
you're way more likely to be productive,
when you listen to it.
That being said, it's kind
of a blessing and a curse.
You have to try really
hard not to goof off,
when you're listening to your
sacred productivity playlist.
Because once you goof off
listening to that music,
your brain will create that pathway.
And it'll be a lot more
easy to goof off again.
So if you don't make it an option,
you can maintain the
sacredness of that playlist,
the sanctity of that playlist.
Create a playlist that you
only use for productivity.
If you already have one,
but you've goofed off while
listening to that music,
make another one, make
new brain associations
with that playlist, and only be productive
while you're listening to it.
(bass techno music)
Tip number three is to use
caffeine the right way.
And yes, I am the guy who made a video
about why you should quit caffeine.
And actually, believe it or not,
I'm not a complete hypocrite,
because I totally stand by
everything I said in that video.
If you want to quit caffeine,
because you're finding you
have too many peaks and valleys
in your energy levels throughout the day,
then I think quitting caffeine
is a very constructive thing to do.
Because when you quit caffeine,
you get a more steady,
reliable energy buzz
throughout the day.
The reason why I've
gotten back on caffeine
is because I actually need
more peaks and valleys
throughout my day because
I do super-focused work
for a short amount of time.
And then I'm done for
the day or, you know,
I will have to run some errands,
and then there'll be
another period of time
where I need another caffeine boost.
And for like two hours,
I'm super focused again.
And then I'm done for the day.
I have a really sporadic
work schedule like that.
So caffeine suits my needs well.
However, it's not enough
to just guzzle that coffee
without being methodical about it.
So I have a couple of tips
on how to use caffeine
the right way, or at least a smarter way.
And my first tip is to not have too much.
If you're exceeding 300
milligrams of caffeine a day,
you might wanna consider
toning it back a little bit.
Because after that I
find that you're kind of,
you're too reliant on it.
It's harder to wake up in the morning.
You get like some crazy crashes,
and you basically develop
a pretty intense chemical
dependency on caffeine.
So if you're under 300 milligrams,
check mark number one.
Check mark number two,
is to space out your
caffeine intelligently.
Don't have it all at once.
Otherwise you'll have a huge crash.
Try to space it out while
not having an empty stomach,
because according to "Caffeine Informer,"
which I've been doing
a lot of research on,
it's a really cool website
to learn more about caffeine.
They recommend you don't have
caffeine on an empty stomach
if you want to avoid the crash.
And lastly, I find that combining
caffeine with L-theanine
really helps mitigate the crash,
helps mitigate the jitters, the anxiety,
and all of that kind of you know,
temporary buzz you feel
when you're on caffeine.
It makes it longer-lasting
and more steady.
So I would recommend getting
yourself some L-theanine.
Make sure you get the dosage, correct.
Don't listen to some random YouTuber
before you put random pills in your mouth.
Consult your doctor, if you have concerns.
Look at the back of the bottle,
all of that stuff.
I am not responsible if
you misuse L-theanine,
but I'm pretty sure it's
fairly harmless, anyways.
Before we dive into the final tip,
let's just have a quick word
from today's video sponsor,
Tiege Hanley.
So according to YouTube analytics,
92% of my audience is male,
especially between the ages of 19 and 35.
So you're a bunch of young
dudes watching, just like me.
So the guys over at Tiege
Hanley sent me a box
of this skincare product.
And I don't know if you
can tell by the videos,
but I typically don't
have the greatest skin
in the world,
mostly because it's fairly
complicated for guys.
Teige Hanley takes the
guesswork out of good skincare.
So all the bottles are
labeled super easily.
It's super simple.
And once you make it a daily habit
to take good care of your skin,
you won't have to worry
about it when you're older.
I know a lot of guys who
are in their forties,
who always say like,
"I really wish I took care of
my skin when I was younger,
because now I look like an old sock."
When you're a young person,
you don't think you need
to take care of your skin,
'cause it looks fairly good anyways,
but you're actually just
future-proofing your skin.
So if you take care of it now,
you're gonna be a pretty
good-lookin' 45 year old,
55 year old, heck I've seen 70-year olds
with better skin than
I currently have now.
And it's because they probably use
something like Tiege
Hanley, (snaps fingers)
or just had really good
genetics, I don't know.
For the "Better Ideas" viewers,
Tiege Hanley is offering
20% off your first box.
So if you're interested
in getting a box of Tiege
Hanley, or just trying it out,
hit that link in the description
or use the coupon code,
"Better Ideas" at checkout.
If you don't like it, cancel it.
But I would recommend getting in the habit
of taking care of your skin.
You'll look sexier, you'll
look younger for longer,
and it's just a good idea in general.
(bass techno music)
So, there's this thing called
the concentration hump.
I just named it now.
It's not an official term,
or anything like that.
Maybe you've experienced
this in your life.
You finally are able to grab
yourself, sit yourself down,
grab yourself. (laughing)
You're finally able to sit down
and start to write your
essay, or file your taxes,
or read the book.
You're at it for about five minutes.
And then that sensation hits you
where you really wanna quit.
Like it's becoming super boring.
It's becoming unbearable.
You're starting to lose focus.
So then you quit, and
you go do something else,
as if five minutes was enough
to do any sort of meaningful work.
But that's because you didn't push through
the concentration hump.
If you're able to stick with an activity
past the 20-minute mark,
then you'll enter the flow state
in which doing that
activity is way easier.
You've probably had a crazy deadline
that you like, the fear
of God is put into you,
and you really just have
to sit down and do it,
regardless if you enjoy it or not.
You've probably found that
once you sit down to do it,
it's kind of hard at first,
but after about 20 minutes of doing it,
you start to get into
a flow and then like,
things are happening around you.
Someone knocks on your door,
and you're like, don't like don't.
It's almost like you're
so into doing that thing,
that nothing else in the world matters.
You've entered the 11th dimension.
And all you have is that
thing in front of you.
That's the flow state.
If you can make it past
the 20-minute mark,
you can enter the flow state.
So tip number four, is be
aware of the flow state.
Try to stick with it, uninterrupted,
for more than 20 minutes.
And I guarantee you
you'll enter a flow state,
assuming that you have
notifications turned off,
which will just completely
ruin the whole thing.
And you'll find that your
most impactful creative work
will be able to be accomplished
with that hyper-focus,
that people seem to lack these days.
You'll be a superpower.
So that's it.
If you like this video,
hit that like button.
If you like videos like these in general,
hit that subscribe button,
join the Facebook page.
We have a Discord now.
We can hear each other's
voices, talk with each other.
If you want to eliminate
Tiege Hanley ads in my videos,
head over to my patreon,
and start donating money,
so that I won't have to have
ads in the middle of my videos.
But if you're interested in Tiege Hanley,
hit that link in the description,
to get 20% off your first box.
Your skin will thank you,
and so will your lady friend.
(melodic classical piano music)